I think these might give me Mom but hey
cuties welcome to ladylike there's no
reason why you can't be comfy and cute
today we're gonna try to style the same
pair of joggers four different way to
show that anyone can rock anything let's
play can I wear that chakras addition I
think joggers are an excuse to wear
pajamas in the social setting joggers
are formal sweatpants I'm pretty sure
most joggers have drawstring ways I
don't know what joggers are my personal
interpretation of joggers is they're a
happy marriage between skinny jeans and
sweatpants they're casual you can wear
them pretty much anywhere and you can
dress them up or down big things that
denote a jogger is they're a little
loose around the waist they can have a
slight drop crotch and the main thing is
they're tapered at the ankle I think as
long as the girls are creative and sort
of embrace what makes them unique then I
think the jogger is versatile enough to
blend in with whatever clothes they
accentuate it with I think it's gonna go
well I think that I might win I'm
stressed about it I fear that these
pants will be loose in the buttock
region and short in the ankle region I
think it'll be a challenge but I'm
excited bring on the joggers there's a
lot of crotch super stretchy I like the
fabric it's kind of fun and like ripoli
like water all right I'm gonna put them
on now I love these I wish every single
pant was as comfortable as this I could
exercise knees if I wanted to but I can
also go out in them if I wanted to this
is my problem like do I have like mom
Jean but all right I'm gonna try and
style these let see what I come across I
am like wearing a lot of collared stuff
cuz it reminds me of my good ol uniform
days I like this a lot
it's kind of like a 90s like zipper
thing so I've really been into poncho I
love animals especially elephants it's a
split all the way up
hello it looks like you have your [ __ ]
together so you're also very comfortable
I think it's gonna be pretty badass
pretty like dark meats light pretty like
devil meat angel I look like someone who
once upon a time worked at Hot Topic and
now I have a real job but I still
remember my roots you know I'm saying my
mom loves to describe me as edgy I'm
gonna go with a little teal I like these
I like this I like these pants what
could go wrong so this is me this is my
outfit I'm definitely feeling it I feel
very easy breezy
I could totally buy a pair of joggers I
could wear these every day these are so
comfortable I do like this little Cape
thing because it effectively hides my
behind I feel like I'm wearing pajama
pants and I'm getting away with a dirty
little secret I could totally curl up at
home and watch a movie or I could party
in this I'm not obsessed everyone should
have a pair of these because they're
really cozy three so can we wear joggers
I think the answer is you know yeah a
hundred percent my ass is in fact jiggly
but you know it's fine cuz there it's
disguised you know like I disguise the
butt